il y a quelques semaines seulement vole
novara été gouvernée par l'ukraine
aujourd'hui c'est l'armée russe qui
monte la garde à l'entrée un z sous le
coeur jaune et bleu en guise de victoire
du kremlin qui affirme non pas avoir
conquis la ville
mais la voir libérée pour de bon libéré
de qui libéré de croix maria shevchenko
n'en n'a aucune espèce d'idée mais elle
a survécu elle dit que c'est pire que la
grande guerre dans laquelle sont perçues
à l'époque qu'il savait pourquoi ils se
battaient aujourd'hui c'est pas clair
qu'est ce qui nous arrive en croise que
ça nous concerne nous et les enfants
si n'importe quoi la destruction est
presque total aucun immeuble n'a été
épargné même pas l'école c'est l'armée
russe qui guide notre équipe dans ce qui
reste de la ville au terme de six
semaines de combats intenses ce sont les
soldats russes aussi qui décide que nous
pouvons voir et à qui nous pouvons
parole dennis push all-in le leader de
la république autoproclamée de donetsk
était là pour donner le temps
aux objectifs
c'est important que ces images et ces
informations soient diffusés consommée
par vos téléspectateurs dit il aux
journalistes en accusant l'ukraine de
s'attaquer aux civils
l'opm un jeu
ces deux garçons ont bel et bien vécu
ces bombardements jour et nuit mais il
ignore exactement ce qui se passe
quand on est caché dans un sous-sol
terrifié s'est jamais clair qui attaque
et de coûts ça venait de tous les côtés
dit il et si ce sont les nazis c'est
difficile de comprendre leurs
motivations
mais aujourd'hui c'est la russie qui les
contrôlent
[Musique]
hymne national pour cette rentrée
scolaire des plus absurdes en pleine
zone de guerre
de la musique et des jeux ont été
organisés pour montrer que la vie
continue alors que les combats
s'intensifient et se concentrent dans
les villes voisines de l'ess difficile
de savoir ce que pensent ces mères qui
surveillent les enfants alors que des
soldats russes s'affairent à déminer les
alentours devant les caméras
beaucoup de familles sont parties en
pologne et en ukraine tout le monde est
dispersée
les enfants semblent libre animé e rhume
à l'intérieur l'angoissent les ronge
encore dit cette maman le deuil ou
s'il a perdu des proches des amis dans
les combats mais il nous montre personne
du doigt
béret ou occupés on s'en fout di maria
l'école reprend la vie continue mais mes
amis ne sont plus là la guerre est une
horreur peu importe la couleur qu'on
brandit ici tamara altérer ce que
radio-canada monde